hello and welcome to this video Mulla
most yeah you don't know right
okay so double fient kato time an idea 3
9 f 6 g 3 g6 is really the most common
move it seems
like a safe time to figure out what he
wants to do
my choice on d6 there is also d5 but
that move is in fact not that great okay
didn't happen you played b6 yeah I don't
want to trade out so much because of my
space advantage
therefore I'm withdrawing the night to
see to see going Knight a5 here maybe
not sure maybe rupee a the system about
preparing preparing an a6 and b5
okay CARICOM 95 now
now you can now play a couple of things
you can play F or F form for a broad
center or still go 95 I mean not now I
mean go for that plan with Ruger to be
one for example or put a knight on to e3
let's do that it's more of a technical
way to play you can oh yeah I could have
played a for f1 form more active central
play where this is just owned going to
be better for white okay take with the
pawn that looks a bit counterintuitive
but you get the space and you get to c6
so 92 to d4 I know it looks slow but if
you clearly see that the piece belongs
on to a certain square you have
sometimes you just have to invest the
time to redo but I want to culture and
won't you go to c6 what's this you're
going to sacrifice the exchange on d5
no it wasn't totally totally weird to do
that also a thought okay
ultimately in 96 is my move but you can
still improve him interesting yes still
I can go F for him and 496 I mean what
is he doing now if he moves the night
yeah the rook is just dropping so what's
going on here or Bishop d5 maybe I
overlooked this no I don't know
um I the thing I know is that I just go
to c6 now he will very likely take it
it's very tough to not take this piece
I'm threatening 97 checkmate I mean Luke
e8 you can probably play but you know
it's a tough move to be tough enough to
make okay so let's go here no just
centralize
there's a hard time to move no that
doesn't work does technically it doesn't
work
97 next it was a pretty awful position
already
yes ob6 not certain him yeah I think d6
is probably best something like before
and now you have the interesting option
to play 94 or take it you know and this
kind of position is always going to be
only a little bit better for watching
nothing special I mean I like this for
white but it's nothing special in 6d
form yeah and now it's a little bit odd
to have this fianchetto played as black
iam a little bit because well it's tough
to play without d6 and then you always
have to deal with this potential
weakness there on c6 yeah here you have
from besides this Queen d2 98
besides 93 you also can go on e4 f4 rook
to e1 just like full-scale central pawn
roller it's also pretty nice maybe this
is stronger than my mouth ninety three
ninety seven that was seems to be the
plan and now this is a very simple way
to play takes takes and he always has to
do something about the knight it's
really tough to play around this piece
and simply accept the night so yeah it
takes it and now yeah I mean every move
is an advantage but this is I think the
most straightforward way and you now
regroup the night to t4 and then you
play for that weak spot on c6 what I was
thinking is actually I went here yeah
rook takes d5 is not totally ridiculous
but yeah the engine agrees I don't have
to take it this is an important factor
and I wouldn't have taken it but I was
thinking something like this first
because the rook cannot
now we have this inin fact and can maybe
delay the whole thing or play E for at
one point and let him take I don't want
to get this the bishop here is strong I
mean it's not it's not terrible for me I
have f3 for example at some point who's
just patch the strongly I know but I
don't have to take immediately this is a
good intermediate move okay
black played here rook c1 is kind of
normal and b5 interesting move that's
interesting so here there is Queen b6
yeah it's nice that's a good resource b5
is a strong move and I can take but that
makes blacks defensive defensive tasks a
bit easy 'm so the engine actually wants
to go f4 here right or b5 the 96 maybe a
maybe that's stronger okay he went Queen
eight and now I think f4 might have been
a mistake because he can take on d5 96
is already a strong move and now we can
take on the fight
I made a technical mistake yeah I saw it
too late
now he's threatening to take him and if
I take on d5 Queen takes this is hanging
with the checker and here I already have
problems so I need to do something like
this it's also not good
yeah that was a big blunder for I played
this probably too quickly I quickly saw
it and could be a problem and yeah
Knight to c6 is already very very good
Lucas is 6m the engine's choice
sacrifice in exchange something like
that you cannot you cannot stand that's
just too much it's too much yeah so the
way it went and my position has just
strategically winning a thunk oh Kim and
for me it's just terrible bishop c8 is
an immediate loss but I just play a
45-year and black gets steamrolled just
nothing to do okay guys thanks for
watching